I think the importance of the thing lies in the need of people,
How much they liked it, and their desire to continue using it.
We are developers of Fril, an app selling cheap goods.
We discovered that a lot of women
They put clothes on their blogs for sale.
So we thought about creating an app that makes it easy to sell and buy clothes
As a good business opportunity.
Most of our users are young, as university students and housewives.
Before launching the application, we interviewed more than 100 women
To test our service.
We have reached the current design in collaboration with users.
As we developed it, we asked users to experiment with a prototype.
We then tested it to ensure that users get the service we want.
We have also benefited from many interviews and surveys on the visual design of the application
So we get to design the users admire.
We have been using this approach since our establishment,
To help instill an institutional culture based on user collaboration in service milestones.
We used the new "multidimensional design" concept
During application development
In a way that does not affect the experience of existing users,
We then launched a 70% version of the multidimensional design.
The result was impressive;
With the retention rate of new users rising by 7%.
Users' time spent on the app also increased by a staggering 200%.
We employ our customer support team from our user base,
And then they are all users of the application.
We use search groups and tests by users
When we decide to add new features and test new designs.
Even the implementation of the modification in the designs is done
Using Android Studio.
It allows you to test using different devices while adjusting the design,
It also features features like code completion, making it easier for designers to use as well.
Because our application is used for buying and selling among individuals,
We can withdraw funds through it,
For example, exposure to errors can cause a major problem.
Contains the Android Application Developer Console
A feature that allows you to cast in stages,
And then you can launch an update of 5% or 20% each time,
This allows you to troubleshoot before they appear.
It's very easy.
Since we've introduced a design that complies with Google's multidimensional design,
User retention increased by 20%
The contribution rate increased by 30%.
It is important to ask yourself whether the product you offer
Meets the need of users and whether the service is sufficient to maintain them as customers.
We chose the Fablic name of our company
It is a word combining the word holic
In the sense of "addiction" and the word fab in the sense of "magnificence".
We aim to achieve the meaning of this name
By providing a service that users will add.